[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Thank you, Meredith.
And a big thank you to
everyone at the Radcliffe.
As you can tell from
this lovely introduction,
this has just been an enormously
supportive and wonderful place
in which for me to start
this new research project.
And I'm also really
happy to have this venue
to share with you today
some of the results
of this research, which I'll be
presenting for the first time.
So what I'd like to
do is introduce you
to the phenomenon known as
the "reproducibility crisis"
via a thought experiment.
Let's imagine that
we took a stack
of recent scientific
journals, and we
decided that we were
going to look through them
for articles that may help
us develop new cancer drugs.
Say we found an
article that showed
that cancer cells with
a particular mutation
were more sensitive
to a particular drug.
And we look through
these journals, both some
of the preeminent
scientific journals
in the world, as well as some
maybe less well-known but still
reputable journals, and we
came up with around 50 articles
that we thought might help
us in developing new cancer
treatments.
Then we took those
articles, took them
to a laboratory, a well-equipped
lab full of scientists
with lots of experience in
doing this type of research,
and said, just see if you can do
these experiments again and get
the same result. When
you take that same cell
with the same mutation and
you treat it with a drug,
do you also find that they're
more sensitive, as was reported
in the publication?
So imagine the
scenario in your head.
And I want you to pick
a percentage of articles
that you think these scientists
can probably recreate.
In this scenario, what
percentage of the findings
do you think our
laboratory scientists would
be able to redo on their own?
And I encourage you to pick
an actual percentage here,
just so you've got kind of
a baseline in your head.
This is very close
to what happened
in a real-life case, where
the pharmaceutical company
Amgen in 2012 decided to
publish their own experience
with trying to recreate results
from the published literature
in their in-house laboratories.
And in this publication,
here is the number
that they reported of
the number of studies
that they could
reproduce in their lab--
11%, 6 out of 53
cases, that they chose.
This article generated
a lot of attention
in the biomedical
research world,
particularly in the
leadership at the National
Institutes of Health.
And it became a
historical turning
point in what's now known as the
reproducibility crisis, which
is a transfield
phenomenon happening
across scientific
disciplines, as we'll see,
where researchers suddenly are
less confident that findings
that they thought were stable
could actually hold true
on closer examination.
So this article
here was a moment
when people really started
paying attention to this.
It shows up high in the citation
lists of key articles coming
from leaders at
the NIH when they
decide to take action
and introduce policies
on reproducibility and rigor
just a few years later.
But one thing that's curious
about this phenomenon is that
in this article and in another
article published by another
pharmaceutical company-- in this
case, Bayer pharmaceuticals--
what the researchers report is
the figure that they're showing
us is, in fact,
common knowledge.
Here's what they say.
The first article from
Amgen pharmaceuticals--
"on speaking with many
investigators in academia
and industry, we found
widespread recognition
of this issue."
"Our findings are mirrored
by 'gut feelings' expressed
in personal communications
with scientists from academia
or other companies, as well
as published observations."
That's the quote from a
similar article in Bayer.
And these assertions here
are not just anecdotal.
They're supported by
other kinds of data.
If we take a look, for example,
at a recent survey conducted
by Nature Publishing
Group in 2016,
Nature asked 1,500 scientists
from across disciplines
whether they'd had any personal
experience with failures
to replicate, if they had
had a case in their own lab
where they experienced
irreproducibility.
And you can see here that
the majority of scientists--
in some cases, the vast
majority of scientists--
reported experiencing a failure
to replicate either someone
else's result or even
their own result.
So this is not just something
that pharmaceutical companies
are telling us anecdotally.
We also see in survey
data that scientists
have widespread experience
with reproducibility--
irreproducibility-- sorry.
And just as a note
here, I'll pause
to say that one of
the things that's
quite unique about the
reproducibility crisis
is that it's really
reaching across fields here.
Chemistry is maybe
not the field where
you would expect to see
widespread irreproducibility
problems, and yet
it's high on the list.
For the purposes of
my talk today, I'm
going to be focusing on
preclinical research, which
is research with animal
models or cell lines
which is aimed, perhaps
indirectly or distantly,
but aimed at affecting
human health.
So that's the area
that I'm going
to be looking at-- the type of
research that the NIH funds,
which is largely things with
cell lines and animal models.
So the take-home here is
it seems as though everyone
has had experience
with irreproducibility,
at least that's what the
survey data and Amgen says.
And yet in this same
survey, Nature also
asked researchers-- do they
feel like this is a crisis?
Almost all of
respondents here said
that they thought it was
some degree of crisis.
And in fact, you can see that
about half of respondents
feel as though it's a
very significant crisis.
So the puzzle that I would
like to lay out for you today,
and this is what most of my talk
is going to be responding to,
is the following one--
how can irreproducibility
be something
that both everyone knows
about and an emerging
crisis that suddenly hit us?
Maybe, in other words, how could
irreproducibility be something
that is hiding in plain sight?
If you think this through,
it doesn't actually
make a lot of sense
that it could be
both of these things at once.
In that thought experiment
that I asked you to do,
my guess is, is that if you
had a number in your head
that was close to 11%, when
I flashed the result up
on the screen, it didn't
really pack that much
of an emotional punch.
And it seems like a true
statement about the world.
And you might be tempted to make
an argument like well, yeah,
most research on the
forefronts of our knowledge
is going to be unstable.
Science is a
low-yield enterprise,
as John Ioannidis, one
of the headline figures
in reproducibility, has said.
But my guess is, is that
if you picked a number that
was substantially higher than
11%, say, 50%, when I flashed
that number up on the
screen, you have a completely
different affective reaction.
Then it feels more
like a crisis precisely
because it doesn't align
with your expectations.
So this is the core
of the puzzle here.
How can this be
something that we all
know about and have
experience with,
and yet somehow this
particular paper feels
like a revelation
where we realize
something is wrong in science?
In my talk for you today,
I'm going to address this
from two different angles.
First, I'm going to
approach this historically,
putting the
reproducibility crisis
into the context of a longer
history of clinical research
reform, which is research
with human subjects.
So the results that
we're talking about here
in the reproducibility
crisis, again,
are those with cell lines,
animal models taking
place in experimental spaces.
But by putting this
into conversation
with clinical
research, we'll see
both how it is that
reproducibility problems could
be invisible and then
suddenly visible.
And then in the second half of
my talk, what I'm going to do
is combine this
historical research
with some ethnographic
research to give us
some purchase on
new ways that we
might begin to think about
addressing irreproducibility
today.
In other words, the question
of-- what does this history
mean for the many
people right now
who are taking this
problem very seriously
and working to solve it?
So I will turn now to the
history of clinical research
reform.
If you read through
this history,
one of the things
that you'll notice
is that there are
a lot of moments
in the history of
clinical research reform
that bear a strong resemblance
to where we're at today.
Take, for example, Harry
Marks' classic book called
The Progress of Experiment.
And he opens this
book with a situation
that sounds very much like
where we're at right now
in the 21st century.
He says, "over the course of
research in the 19th century,
researchers working
in a variety of fields
noticed a common problem--
individual observers,
putatively studying
the same phenomenon
with similar techniques,
gave divergent accounts of it."
One of the examples that
he talks about in his book
is an early 20th century remedy
introduced to help pneumonia.
And this was one of these
tricky cases where doctors
reported different effects.
For some, the serum seemed
to work really well.
In other cases, it didn't
seem to be effective at all.
And it was difficult
to interpret
exactly what this
irreproducibility situation
meant.
Was it because the doctors
who were using the serum
were simply not accurately
diagnosing pneumonia
and therefore using it
in the wrong patients?
Or was it something about the
drug itself, the serum itself,
that was not working well?
And what Marks
argues in this book
is it's exactly these
kinds of concerns
that lead to the development
of the modern day
system of randomized
controlled clinical trials.
The way that we
now evaluate drugs
for their effectiveness in
these large clinical trials
is born, Marks argues, out
of this moment of concern
about irreproducibility.
There are lots of
other parallels
in this book between the
kinds of problems happening
in the clinical research world
throughout the 20th century
and the types of
reforms proposed
and what's going on today.
But the story that
I want to tell you
is not just one that's
about similarity.
This is not one that's
just about history
reproducing itself
or repeating itself.
It is instead one about how
it is that clinical research
reforms actively make invisible
problems going on in the lab
and then suddenly reveal them.
So there is a more
direct connection.
What I'm going to do here
is I'm going to pick up
where Marks leaves off.
He ends this book
here in the 1990s.
And I'm going to
start in the 1990s
with a couple of
historical events
that show us how we
get to this moment
where we can have an aha
moment about irreproducibility.
The first event that I want
to talk about in the 1990s is
the rise of what's called
"evidence-based medicine"
taking place here in the
late 1980s and early 1990s.
And the evidence-based
medicine movement
is born out of a
concern that doctors
are making clinical
decisions, really,
without respect to the
scientific evidence,
either because that
evidence is hard for them
to access because it's scattered
throughout the literature
or because they're trusting
their clinical intuition more
than they're trusting what's
out there in the science.
And so evidence-based
medicine reformers, then,
sought to try and collect,
evaluate the strength of,
and then compile
scientific evidence for use
by practitioners who are
out there in the clinic
treating patients.
One good example of an
organization founded in 1993
that probably many of
you will have heard of
is the Cochrane Collaboration,
now today just called
the Cochrane, that
does exactly that.
It gathers up evidence
for clinicians,
tries to answer a meaningful
clinical question and say,
here's what you
should do if you want
to make your decision based
on the scientific evidence.
Now it's important to note
here that in the early days
of the evidence-based
medicine movement,
this is a movement that's about
collecting science and giving
it to researchers.
It's not a movement which
is about critiquing science.
And yet, the techniques
that evidence-based medicine
researchers use to try
and compile this evidence
ends up revealing systematic
flaws in clinical research.
How does this happen?
I'll give you an
example here using
this cryptic little
graphic that's
at the core of the
Cochrane's logo.
What this is is it's
a stylized image
of what's called a forest plot.
And a forest plot
is a visualization
of what happens when
you try and combine
the information from
multiple studies
or multiple clinical
trials together.
So to walk you through
the information
that we're getting
from this graphic here,
each of these lines here
represents a different study.
So say, for example,
we found in our review
of clinical practices that
prostate cancer patients
in one area of the United
States are eight times as
likely to get their prostates
removed in early stage cancer
as patients in another
area of the United States
where physicians are
practicing differently.
And we, the Cochrane,
say, OK, let's
take a look at the
available evidence
and decide whether or not
surgery actually helps
early stage prostate patients.
So we take all of
the clinical trials
that have evaluated this.
And each one of these gets
represented by this little box.
The size of the box represents
the number of patients
in each clinical trial.
And it's spatialization
on this scale
here represents whether the
outcome of the clinical trial
show that the treatment
was effective or not.
This middle line here
represents the equipoise point,
the point at which
the treatment doesn't
seem to do anything for people.
So if your results are
right in the middle,
it doesn't seem to matter
if you get surgery or not.
If the boxes are
leaning this way,
that means that
surgery did actually
impact whatever our
outcome marker was,
say, the number of years
that these prostate cancer
patients lived.
Now if it's leaning
the other way,
then that says that actually
maybe the surgery harmed them.
It might have actually
reduced their lifespan because
of the complications of surgery.
So what this thing is
here is a forest plot
is it's a way of giving you all
of that information about all
these clinical trials
in one graphic.
And everything is summed
up by this diamond
here at the bottom, which is the
statistical combination of all
of those trials together.
So if you want to know what
does the literature say,
there's your diamond.
But what I'd like you to notice
is that this very same graphic
doesn't just give you
information about similarity.
It also gives you
information about difference.
By comparing all of the clinical
trials together in one graphic,
now you can look
at this and you can
start to ask questions like,
huh, this clinical trial has
much more strongly positive
results than the rest.
This one over here is
leaning a little bit
towards the negative
effect side.
And then you can
ask questions like,
I wonder what accounts for the
differences in the outcomes
between these clinical trials?
For example, if I take a look
at all the clinical trials that
have been funded by the
pharmaceutical industry,
do I find that they're leaning
more in the positive direction?
These are the kinds of
questions that researchers
within the
evidence-based movement--
evidence-based medicine
movement then begin to ask.
And asking these questions and
producing the answers to them
by the mid-2000s has started to
reveal some very serious flaws
in the system of
clinical trials,
particularly in
drug development.
So for example,
one of the problems
that this type of
research reveals
is what's called publication
bias or selective publication.
And the problem is as follows.
Let's say you're a
doctor, and you're
interested in prescribing
an antidepressant.
So you go and take a
look at the literature
to see what the clinical trials
say about the effectiveness
of the antidepressant.
And you look, and you see
what's been published.
All the studies seem to
indicate that it's pretty good.
So you go home
confident, thinking
there is strong evidence for
my use of this antidepressant
in a clinical setting.
But now imagine for a moment
that all of the trials that
showed negative results, where
the drug didn't help people
or maybe it actually
harmed them,
those ones just
haven't been published.
They didn't make it into
the published literature.
Or maybe they are just in
lower-tier journals, where
you're less likely to look.
And in the mid-2000s,
what we see
is some revelations
here of some instances
in which pharmaceutical
companies actively
suppressed the publication
of clinical trials
with negative results,
thereby creating
a misleading impression of
the efficacy of those drugs
in the published literature.
So this New England
Journal of Medicine article
tries to show you
systematically just that--
how it is that the
effect size of this drug
has been artificially
inflated by having
those studies with positive
results placed in better
journals and having the ones
that have negative results
simply not appear at all.
And for those of you
in the audience who
might be psychologists or
historians of psychology,
one of the names
that you'll probably
recognize on this
author list here
is Robert Rosenthal, one of
the founders of meta-analysis
within the field of psychology.
So you can see some
fairly direct connections
here how it is that
meta-analysis is leading
through into this new
research agenda which
is about probing difference.
These issues here are not
merely academic issues.
They are issues that
get a lot of attention
within the popular sphere and
within politics, particularly
when Marcia Angell, who is
the former editor in chief
of the New England
Journal of Medicine,
where this article
was published,
writes this really scathing
popular press book in 2004
detailing all of the ways in
which she saw, in her position
as editor in chief,
pharmaceutical companies
manipulating data in these
ways in order to make
their products look better.
And this leads by the mid-2000s
to a bunch of reforms,
such as legislation requiring
that pharmaceutical companies
must register their trials in
a publicly available data base
so that, in theory, you
could go out and look and see
if there were trials
with negative results
that were conducted but
then never published.
So the pharmaceutical
industry is
having a bad time in the first
decade here of the 21st century
because of these
numerous scandals
that have to do with
the conduct of research.
And that's not the only problem
that the industry is facing.
The second thing that's
going on in the '90s, maybe
more visible in
the early 2000s, is
declines in the productivity
of the pharmaceutical industry.
So in this image
here, what you see
is the number of new drugs
approved each year by the FDA
plotted with R&D, or Research
and Development, expenditure
on the part of
pharmaceutical companies.
Now commentators
such as Marcia Angell
have been very critical
of this nice, neat curve
here that you see on the R&D
side, which they've argued
is maybe kind of fictitious.
But nonetheless, if we
just take a look here
at the molecular entity
output, or the number of drugs
being approved,
year over year, you
can see that it's declining.
Moreover, what you don't see
from this graph is that a lot
of these drugs that are being
approved by the FDA at this
time are what's
called "me-too drugs,"
meaning they're very similar
to drugs that exist already
on the market--
say, yet another statin
to treat your cholesterol,
when we've already got a bunch
of statins available to us.
So the concern is,
is both we're seeing
a decline in the number
of drugs approved,
and the drugs that
are getting approved,
they're not really
breakthroughs.
They're kind of incremental
improvements on patient care,
if they're really
improvements at all.
So this is an issue that
is of great concern here,
both to the pharmaceutical
industry, obviously,
but also to entities
like the NIH that see it
as their mission to try
and improve human health.
And it seems like something
is going wrong here.
The explanation that people
give for what's going wrong
is the following.
The argument in the
2000s is, is that we
have a translational
research problem.
We have good science
going on over here.
We've got clinical development
partners over here.
But we simply can't bridge
the gap between them.
If you take a look
at this graph here
in the context of the
other information presented
in the original
article, what you'll see
is that this graph is positioned
right next to this other one
here, which shows NIH grants and
where the NIH grants are going.
And the story, you can
see just from the way
that this is plotted,
is that the NIH
is giving all this money to
PhDs, not to MDs, or MDs-PHDs,
and presumably,
the implication is,
is that by giving money
to basic researchers,
they're not really
well-positioned
be able to carry
through the knowledge
that they find into the clinic.
Another way of illustrating this
is with this nice graphic that
accompanies the article,
which plays on the term
that the article uses called
"the valley of death."
Nice, right?
And the idea here is that
you've got your bench scientist
over here represented with
test tubes and flasks.
You've got your clinician
over here with a patient.
And this terrible rickety bridge
is all that's connecting them.
The argument here being is
that we produce knowledge
that fails to
actually make it over,
and good ideas die in
the valley of death.
And this was an image
that was used ubiquitously
when I was doing fieldwork
in the cancer community
around 2010, 2011.
This was the common
and accepted narrative
for what was going wrong.
What's going wrong?
We're not moving our knowledge
from the bench to the bedside.
And with this narrative
in mind, the NIH
invested quite a bit of money in
the 2000s in that first decade
of the 21st century trying to
develop translational research
infrastructure,
trying to do things
to solve what they thought
was the problem here--
this problem.
So now we're in a
position to return back
where we started to this Amgen
article published in 2012
and to see why it
is that somebody
from the pharmaceutical
industry was positioned
to write this thing and why
it is that the NIH took it
very seriously when it was
published in the literature.
In their article, Begley
and Ellis, the researchers
here from Amgen--
actually, only one of them
is from Amgen, but
that doesn't matter.
What they're doing here
is there responding
to a familiar problem about
this lack of productivity
in the pharmaceutical
industry, but they're flipping
the script a little bit.
And they're positioning the
problem in a different place.
They're saying the problem
is not translation,
getting things from
bench to bedside.
The problem is that
the science itself,
that preclinical
research, it's not good.
There are systemic
problems in that research.
So it's a recognized
problem, but it's
a different way of
formulating the problem,
a way that most people had
not thought of it before.
Moreover, the
pharmaceutical industry
argued that it was in
a really good position
to try and see these flaws
precisely because of all
the scandals that
they had weathered
in the previous decade about the
quality of their own research.
So if the
pharmaceutical industry
had been getting hit hard with
negative press about the way
that it conducted
its experiments, when
it was looking across
the hallway, so to speak,
at the bench scientists and
seeing the way that they
did their research, they said,
we see these same problems.
So how is it that
irreproducibility in the lab
could be both widely
experienced and sort
of hiding in plain sight?
Well, it was a problem
that everyone recognized,
but it was a problem
that people assumed
existed in a different place
of the so-called "pipeline."
Everyone was thinking
the problem was
with the quality of clinical
research, or translation,
not with the quality of
basic research itself--
so an accepted problem, but
a really new formulation.
So now what I'm going to do
with this historical foundation
in place is switch gears here
in the second half of the talk
and focus more on
two lessons that we
can learn from this history.
And the first lesson that
I want to draw out of this
is that I think we really
need better ways of talking
about certainty or uncertainty
in scientific information.
One of the things that happens
during the '90s with the rise
of the evidence-based
medicine movement
is we see the proliferation
of vocabularies and systems
for trying to talk about
the relative strength
of clinical evidence.
For example,
probably many of you
will have seen something
like this thing,
the pyramid of evidence or the
levels of evidence pyramid.
This particular one is taken
from an evidence-based medicine
published in 2000,
but there are lots
of variations that pop
up in places elsewhere
with slight tweaks as to
what's included in it.
But what this thing is,
really, is a motivation
or a way of trying to
get clinicians thinking
about the differential
strength of the evidence
that they're basing
their opinions on--
i.e.
not all forms of evidence
are created equal
or should be treated as equal.
So this graphic is
trying to remind you--
randomized clinical trials
are better evidence than,
for example, an expert's
opinion who's saying,
based on my years of clinical
experience, here's what I do.
You should take that with
a bigger grain of salt
than something that
comes from an RCT.
So this is part
of the development
of a vocabulary for how to
talk about degrees of certainty
within the clinical information.
A second example-- this
is a web page taken
from the website UpToDate.
The text here is not important.
What I would like you
to notice, though,
is these little
brackets that I've
highlighted that contain
these cryptic codes grade
1C, grade 1B.
What this thing is
is it's another kind
of evidence-based
medicine invention,
again, founded in
the 1990s, which
is a subscription-based
service where
doctors who are
practicing in the clinic
can go and quickly look up
the best available evidence
on a particular topic.
So if you want to know how to
treat a patient with leiomyoma,
you can go and see--
here's the evidence.
What these things
in brackets, though,
are when you click
through on them,
they're little notes about
the strength of the evidence
and-- importantly here--
to which kinds of patients
the evidence applies,
recognizing that not
all patients are similar
and a clinical trial that
was done, say, in an older
population may
not actually apply
to your younger patient who's
sitting there in front of you.
So with each of
these recommendations
within this text--
grade 2B, grade 1C, you can
click through, and you'll see--
this is a weak recommendation.
We see places where
you might want
to go against this in
your clinical practice.
Or this is a strong
recommendation.
Most patients should
be treated in this way.
So this is another example
of a kind of vocabulary
that clinicians are developing
to try and say, all right,
here's the relative
strength of the data.
Now in contrast, compare that
to the preclinical world,
where there are relatively few
or reasonably underdeveloped
vocabularies for talking
about differential
certainty in your data.
This is one of the
things that I spent
quite a lot of time
studying in my first book
here, Model Behavior, where
I was in this laboratory
with researchers who
were using mouse models
of psychiatric disorders.
And they themselves
saw, as Meredith said,
all kinds of uncertainties
in their own research.
And so I was interested in,
how did they communicate this,
then?
How did they let you
know that they're not
entirely confident in
what they're doing?
Take, for example,
this test, one which
I spent a lot of time studying.
It's called the
elevated plus maze.
And it's a research
setup that researchers
use both in basic
research and drug
development to study anxiety.
What you do is you
take your mouse,
you put it at the
center of the maze,
and then you measure how much
time it spends hanging out
in these closed areas
of the maze that
have the high protected
walls versus hanging out
on these open platforms--
very commonly used test.
So how is it that researchers
signaled their uncertainty
about what was going on here
and how much of a good test
this actually was?
They called it "a test of
anxiety-like behavior"--
really rolls off
the tongue, right?
I was really
curious when I first
entered the lab to hear
people saying things like,
well, in this test of
anxiety-like behavior
or in this
depression-relevant phenotype.
And they would say
that all the time,
even when they were
talking amongst themselves.
Why did they do this?
This vocabulary mattered
to them because it inserted
that little bit of uncertainty
that what they were studying
was not anxiety.
It was anxiety-like.
It seemed like anxiety, but it
was not exactly the same thing.
This vocabulary was one
that worked quite well
within this particular
group of researchers
who knew what they
were talking about,
but you try and take
this vocabulary outside
of the laboratory to communicate
uncertainty to someone,
and it kind of falls apart.
No one knows what you mean.
It just sounds
like you're saying
something overly complicated.
And the journalist
will say to you,
can we call it a
test for anxiety?
And the scientist
will sort of shrink.
In fact, one of the hallmarks
of the reproducibility crisis
is the loss of the
one common vocabulary
that bench scientists
and many others
tend to use for
expressing degrees
of certainty, which
is null hypothesis
testing and p-values.
These have recently
come under fire
from very prominent
statisticians
for being misused,
over-interpreted,
under-interpreted, and generally
bad ways of communicating
the degree of confidence that
we should have in findings.
So the point that
I want to make here
is that, really, the moment
that we're living in,
we have a lack of a
vocabulary for dealing with
or communicating uncertainty.
What do we have instead?
Well, in the popular
press, what we
have is a lot of
conversation about truth.
And truth is not
a great language
for talking about shades of
gray because truth, generally
speaking, seems binary.
We have truth.
We have falsity.
We have truth or post-truth.
We don't have
truthiness, exactly.
And so when these
conversations are taking place
in the popular press that
are focused on truth,
the idea that the
truth is wearing off
or that research is unreliable
gives you the sense of crisis.
It gives you the sense that
something has gone wrong.
There is no indication
here that maybe we just
need to downgrade our
confidence in particular ways
or particular situations.
It seems like science
has just failed, broken.
And you can see
from the images here
of people falling through
space, like the whole thing--
the rug has come out
from underneath of them.
So truth and falsity--
I think, a poor language
for talking about this.
And yet, we do see
practitioners attaching
onto this very same language.
Here's a group of scientists
and librarians at University
of Utah who are doing a lot of
organizing and infrastructure
building around reproducibility.
And what did they choose as
their social media campaign
hashtag?
#makeresearchtrue.
You can tell what
they're going for here.
And yet, the implication of
this is, well, what is it now?
False?
So it's not a good vocabulary
for trying to express
degrees of certainty.
And I think that this
is one of the traps
that we find ourselves in here
with the reproducibility crisis
in preclinical research,
in particular, is
that that same infrastructure
for talking about shades
of gray in terms
of our confidence,
it doesn't really exist.
The second lesson that I
think is to be learned here
from thinking about the
reproducibility crisis
in the context of
clinical research reform
is that we need a
lot more attention
to the dynamics of power
within research laboratories.
Now if you put the
history of reproducibility
in preclinical
research side by side
with that of clinical
research, one
of the things that you're
going to notice immediately--
or that I notice-- is
that it's a lot harder
to tell a good
story about what's
going on in the labs
versus the story
that I told you about the
pharmaceutical industry.
And that's because the
pharmaceutical industry
makes a really good
villain in the story.
So if you want to
say things like we
have a problem of
selective reporting here,
you can tell an easy
story about that.
You can say, well, that's
because the pharmaceutical
industry really only cares
about making profits and selling
its drugs.
And that's the reason why
they're selectively reporting.
Now if you turn that
around and think
about the context
of the laboratory,
here, it's a lot
more uncomfortable
because its researchers
themselves calling out
other researchers
on their practices
and because it's
not entirely clear
what the driving motivation is.
So the problem of selective
reporting in the basic research
world--
is that because of pressure
to publish from funders,
from your tenure committee,
from journals who
want to publish novel results?
Or is it internal?
Is it your own biases?
And what you can see
from this survey here
is that in the various ways
of interpreting whether or not
this is an external pressure or
something coming from within,
people are tending to choose the
external pressure narrative--
pressure to publish coming
from somewhere else.
And this makes a lot of sense.
And I have some deep sympathy
with the scientists that
are trying to grapple
with this because
in this particular case,
it's like the call's coming
from inside the house.
So it's a lot
harder to figure out
how to talk about this thing.
I want to pause here
at this point here
and give a shout out to
my Radcliffe research
fellows who are
this year mapping
with me this discursive space
about the various problems
that people identify and the
solutions that they point to.
And unfortunately, we don't
have the data yet ready
for prime time to show you, so
I'm relying on this survey data
instead.
But we're doing a lot more
work to comprehensively map
the things that
people are pointing
to as the sources of
problems and suggesting
as potential solutions.
So externalizing narratives
are kind of the fare of the day
here.
And yet we have a
large body of research
that I've contributed to in
science and technology studies
on what the internal dynamics
of the laboratory look
like that we can draw
to think about some
of the sources of the problems.
For example, I'll
take here a classic
of laboratory ethnography.
This is one of the
first works where
a sociologist, in this case,
decided to go inside the lab
and study scientific
cultures as cultures
in all of their richness.
And conveniently for us, he
focused on reproducibility.
One of Harry
Collins' key insights
is that no two experiments
are ever the same.
And so in trying to decide
what's similar enough
to count as a
replication, that's
the place in which a lot of
human judgment and human bias
starts to creep in.
For example, say you've
got two researchers here--
in this case, myself and my
little sister on a family
vacation looking fabulous.
In many ways, we're
quite similar.
We've got the same haircut.
We've got the same
dresses and sandals.
We were raised in
the same house.
But in some significant
ways, we're also different.
We don't share all
of our genetics.
Perhaps we're working in labs
that have different equipment.
Perhaps one of us is a
more skilled researcher
than the other.
So are we similar enough for
the purposes of comparison?
Or are we different
in meaningful ways?
That's a judgment where
often culture plays in
because we tend to pay attention
to some kinds of things
more than others.
Now in the real-life case
that Harry Collins was talking
about, he was looking at
early '80s experimentation
around gravitational waves.
And he was studying two
different laboratories,
one of whom had
conducted an experiment
and claimed to
have found evidence
of gravitational waves,
and a second laboratory
that conducted an experiment and
said they found no such thing.
And what Collins does is he
looks at how the debate carries
out and how it is
that scientists
try to decide what's real,
in this case, and what's not.
And he points out that this
second experiment, this failure
to replicate, is very
unclear because it
could be that they just didn't
find gravitational waves.
It could be that the
experiment was also bad.
Maybe their equipment
didn't work.
Maybe they weren't as
competent experimenters.
So it's not entirely
clear how to judge this.
And this is why the debate
plays out for a long time.
But importantly, the case
that Harry Collins here
is talking about is one where
we have two high-status,
well-funded labs who are trying
to debate whose results should
be taken as credible.
This is not the way that
irreproducibility presents
itself most of the time.
If you think about
biomedicine and who
does most of the research
in the biomedical world,
it's graduate students.
And that power
differential is something
that we really need to
take into account when
thinking about how easy it is
to recognize irreproducibility.
So what I'm going
to show you now here
is a clip from a training
video produced by the NIH.
And this clip is meant to be
shown to graduate students
in the context of,
say, a lab meeting
to talk about irreproducibility
in their own lab
and how it is that they're
going to address it.
And I think this video will
make pretty clear for you
some of the issues of
power differentials
that I've been talking about.
So I'll play this clip.
It's about two or
so minutes long.
- I performed the
experiment exactly
as Donna described
it in her protocol.
And compared with her results,
mine just aren't matching up.
I just can't get the results to
be statistically significant.
- Well, something may be wrong
with the way you're doing it,
then.
- I guess.
- This is the fourth protocol
that Donna perfected when she
was postdocing here in the lab.
I mean, this is a
good study design.
I really don't get why you
can't reproduce it either.
- I'm following everything to
the T exactly as described.
It's just so weird
that it won't work.
- Well, let me ask you this,
how many samples did you use?
- I used eight mice per group.
- Let's try this.
Add two more mice to each group.
Then try a different
statistical method.
If I remember
correctly, I believe
Donna performed a two-way ANOVA.
See if changing those
parameters gets you the results
we're looking for here.
- That's a good idea.
Remember, Robin, toss out
anything greater than 10.
The normal range for living
cells is three to seven,
so anything higher than that
is probably due to cell death.
So keep that in mind.
It could make a difference.
- OK.
Thanks, Jamal.
- And let me know
how you do, OK?
- Of course, Dr. Fielding.
- Please, call me Harry.
- Dr. Fielding.
- Hey, she's new.
You did the same thing.
- No, I didn't.
- Yes, you did.
- Oh, come on.
- Second scene.
- So where are we here?
- I did what you said, and I
added the two mice per group.
And look, it's still not
statistically significant.
These results are inconclusive,
and they don't match
with Donna's results at all.
- And you varied the
statistical test,
ran a two-way ANOVA this time?
- Yes.
I mean, why is this happening?
- Robin, I've been watching you
a little bit in the lab here.
And I hate to say
this, but it seems
like you're struggling a bit.
- What?
- Sometimes students
come in here and just
can't hack it in grad school.
- It's just embarrassing that
I can't repeat this test.
- I'm worried, too.
We do consistently
high-quality work here, Robin.
We just can't afford to lower
our standards like this.
- I'm sorry, Dr. Fielding.
- So that's half of the video.
In the second half, the PI
realizes the error of his ways,
that his postdoc Robin has been
doing good science all along,
does a mea culpa, and
everything is resolved.
But I think that
you can probably
imagine it's a pretty
reasonable hypothesis
to assume that the story ends
in exactly this place in a lot
of other moments in history.
We can see here that there
are power dynamics at play,
overlaid with race and
gender, that are really
determining here
how we interpret
the outcome of a
failure to replicate.
This is a third way in which
irreproducibility could
be hiding in plain sight--
that we're seeing
irreproducibility and just
misclassifying it as error
on the part of the people
that are doing the research.
This is something here that
we see a little bit coming up
in reproducibility
conversations.
Obviously, I've taken this
out of the NIH's own training
guide.
But it is not something that
is as visible as it really
needs to be.
For example, if we take a look
at the discussion guide that
accompanies this video
that the NIH provides
for you to talk
to your lab, they
put their finger on
precisely the problem
that Harry Collins identifies.
How do you know what normal is
if you don't know the result?
There is that interpretive
space where human judgment is,
where you're saying, is
this a correct result,
or is this an error?
Is this a true finding--
that there's nothing
there-- or is it
simply that we didn't
try hard enough
to set up this experiment?
So they've got their
finger on the problem,
but when it comes
to actually talking
about the power dynamics that
would play into that judgment,
here's where they
really back off.
This is what the
question in the guide
says with respect to Dr.
Fielding's treatment of Robin.
Do you think Dr. Fielding
was too hard on Robin?
Was there a more appropriate
and effective approach
that he could have
taken when Robin was
struggling to replicate
Donna's results?
So really, what's
being ignored here
is that the PI in this
case wasn't asking him
this question about what
is normal and what's not.
He believed that he knew already
what the correct result was--
the one that his prior
postdoc had already published
and that he had his name
on in the literature.
And he believed instead that
what his graduate student was
doing was simply error.
And certainly, he
was likely to believe
that because of
the power dynamics
of having the people on
the frontlines of science
being the most junior
people in the lab,
combined with all of the
race and gender overtones
that are very clear
in that video.
This is something that
I think that we urgently
need to address because of
the interpretive flexibility
about the solutions that
people are posing to problems
of irreproducibility.
If you remember the chart
of solutions or problems
that I showed you before,
here's its corresponding chart
of solutions, again, from
this 2016 survey in Nature
Publishing Group.
And you'll see here that, in
fact, teaching and mentoring
make a prominent appearance--
better mentoring,
supervision, better teaching,
more time for mentoring, more
incentives for reproduction--
or incentives for
better practice, rather.
So there's a lot of things that
are searching around this area
to try and deal
with this problem,
but it matters
crucially whether or not
we think about the power
dynamics inside of labs
when addressing them.
If better mentoring
means finding ways
to take seriously
information that's
coming at us from the people
on the frontlines of science,
then great.
That's something that
sounds like it will help.
But if better mentoring
instead means just continuing
to assume that new
graduate students are
likely to get it
wrong and we need
to help them find ways to get
the results that we expect,
that is not going to help
irreproducibility at all.
So this is something
that I think we urgently
need more attention to.
So to sum it up,
despite the fact that I
have ended in not a very
hopeful place, I would say,
I'd like to emphasize
that I think
that the overall
story that I'm telling
is one that should
make us feel hopeful.
We've spent a lot of
time over the years,
rightly, looking at problems
in clinical research
within the biomedical community.
And we can see irreproducibility
in preclinical research
not as a sudden, emergent
crisis, a thing that
took us all by surprise and
shows that science is losing
its truth, but as a continuation
of those reforms, an extension
of the reforms that have
happened in the clinical trial
world and continue to
happen and that are now
playing out in the laboratory.
We're identifying many
of the same problems.
But this moment of reform
is undoubtedly trickier
to deal with.
For one, it's more
difficult for a community
to look critically
at its own practices
than it is to look at
a for-profit industry,
like the pharmaceutical
industry,
and point out the problems.
That requires some
self-reflection,
which is difficult to do.
Taking these problems
seriously also require
talking about the power
differentials within the lab,
as I have emphasized here.
And confronting that
requires confronting the idea
that science is not
separate from society
with all of its issues
and social biases.
It reminds us that
science is done by humans
and that we have to think about
science as an activity embedded
in society in order to make
progress on these issues.
And finally, think about how
to talk about scientific data
in ways that don't rely on the
absolutist notion of truth,
but instead emphasize
those shades of gray.
That's something
that feels, again,
deeply uncomfortable in this
particular historical moment
that we find ourselves
in, where the idea
of truth in post-truth politics
seems to be up for grabs.
So it's not easy, but these are
issues that we can and should
strive to make progress
on, even if they're not
immediately fixable.
And the kind of
research that I do
is aimed at trying
to tell narratives
about what's going on that will
help us more directly identify
the problems so that we can
spend our efforts in the places
that I think really matter.
Thank you for your attention.
I would love to hear your
thoughts on this material.
[MUSIC PLAYING]